HARISH JAYAKUMAR:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to our session,
Modernized Legacy Job
Application with Anthos.
I'm Harish Jayakumar.
I lead the application
modernization solutions team.
And today along with me
for this talk I have Ameer.
AMEER ABBAS: Hello everybody.
My name is Ameer Abbas.
I am a solutions architect
out of San Francisco.
HARISH JAYAKUMAR: Thanks Ameer.
So, quick guidelines.
All these slides that
we'll be sharing today
and all the
information is Google
confidential proprietary.
It's shared under NDA.
So please be careful what you
share and how you use them.
With that, let's get started.
So when we talk with customers
and any C-level executives,
they all have a digital
initiative in the organization.
But the problem with
executing those initiatives
is that there are a
lot of legacy systems
that hinder the business
agility while consuming
the majority of the IT spend.
And when we talk about
this majority of IT spend,
we talk about
legacy applications,
like Java and [INAUDIBLE]
applications, which
is based on very, very tightly
coupled architectures and messy
integrations.
And these legacy
systems, therefore,
inhibit achieving any cost
efficiencies across the board,
across managing these
legacy applications
in new applications, maintaining
security and compliance
requirements, and ensuring
quality of service
to the customer and
reliability of solutions,
as well it's also going to
prevent them from the agility
in shipping new features
to their customers as well.
So modernizing Java
systems is a priority
for many enterprise customers.
So as you can see from
the statistics over here,
we've seen more that
80% of companies
are saying they're
continue to leverage
the past investments
in Java applications.
And 40% of the companies will
modify these legacy Java apps
for cloud migration.
79% will modernize Java apps
with cloud-native technologies
with containers in
Kubernetes as well.
So as you can see,
Java clearly dominates
when it comes to deploying
application and production
environments.
And that's going to be the
focus of the topic today.
So what are the challenges in
modernizing these legacy Java
applications?
First off, rewrite is
not a viable option
for many workloads.
Yes, you might want to take and
rewrite all these applications.
But think about a company that
has hundreds and thousands
of legacy applications.
It becomes really,
really complicated.
Sometimes, these
applications are so old,
they don't even have
access to the source code
or the developers who actually
wrote those applications are
no longer here.
Second thing is, yeah.
The question I get
asked is, well,
why can't we just
lift and shift to VMs?
Sure, it's a safe bet.
But there are a lot
of those benefits
from the new
technologies [INAUDIBLE]..
And there's also a
significant cost increase
due to lack of
density per host VMs.
And then finally, the thing
that I tell the customers
is that most importantly, we
don't see app organization
as a binary problem.
Even if you can get--
if you can't get all the
benefits, customers are like,
can I get some of the benefits?
And that's what I talk
about when we say meeting
the customers where they are.
Depending on your
risk of portfolio,
depending on the
application portfolio,
we have choices to take them
anywhere that they want.
Which brings us to what
is Google's point of view
when it comes to modernization.
It basically is the
future of applications
and the infrastructure
that they run on
is created with containerized
micro services, managed
to a declarative system.
And declarative
system is where code
represents the final state.
So Kubernetes is
a perfect example.
With the single
control experience
that uses a service mesh to span
all the applicable locations.
So service mesh, as you know,
is a configurable low latency
infrastructure that
ensures communication
among these continuous
applications.
So, now that you have
these applications running
in these containers, you want
to be ensuring that there's
mutual [INAUDIBLE] you get
all those components right out
of the box using service mesh
to span all applicable locations
[INAUDIBLE].
And how do we take
all of that we
want to achieve at modernization
and put it into a solution,
just call it Anthos.
So Anthos is a managed
application platform
that's based on Kubernetes,
Istio, and Knative
for enterprises that want
faster modernization, right?
And we talk about
this work up when
I say, tools to perform
no touch migration.
And greater consistency in a
hybrid and multi cloud world.
So, when we talk with
customers, quickly what happens
is we first work
with them and see
how we can help them see the
business benefits that they
associate with the same problem
that we started off first.
Here's an example of a Java
landscape in a software
company.
As you can see over here,
the estimated benefits
of a three year period
totally pays off.
In fact, even in year one,
after the investment in Anthos,
you can see, the licensing
cost and support for Java
workloads that they're getting
positive as well as being
able to refactor migration cost
here to modernization as well.
80% of them were
due to refactoring
of the Java legacy applications
and the other apps as well.
But how do we go
about doing this?
We call this a very simple
three-step process, right?
Step one is we migrate
the application as is.
And this is where I'm going
to say that it's a lift
and modernize, not
a lift and shift.
Because we're taking
the application and we
are converting
them to containers.
And the business benefit is
immediately in that first step.
You're able to see that 37% TCO
savings right out of the box.
Now that you have
this as a container,
you can actually connect
it to an automated testing
and deployment to a [INAUDIBLE]
process or whatever.
And then at your leisure, you
can refactor and [INAUDIBLE]
form.
And as a combination, you can
see an extra 78% TCO savings.
So let's start
categorizing these apps.
Not all apps are the same.
So when it comes to Java
application categories,
we have actually categorized
them into four buckets.
First is the applications that
are using modern frameworks.
These are prime candidates
for containerization.
[INAUDIBLE] the term
Greenfield applications.
So if your customers or
you are using anything
like web applications,
RESTful APIs, a Spring Boot,
those are great candidates which
we can quickly take and move
them to containers using
Dev Tools to containerize
[INAUDIBLE] we have.
Second, we have
packaged applications.
So these are, you know,
commercial, off-the-shelf
components.
Maybe, you know, you
don't own the source code
for these applications
at all anymore.
So you can take this as well.
And you can actually
use Migrate for Anthos
and move them to containers
just like I talked about.
And the third bucket it is
Brownfield applications.
To clarify, when I say
Brownfield applications,
it's not a new application.
It's not Greenfield.
But there is
applications is running,
it's still generating revenue.
An active code is being
checked and the features
are being checked.
And these could be
in your-- again,
Monolithic, Legacy App
Servers, WebLogicSphere.
These are also great candidates
for Migrate for Anthos,
or some of the GSI
tools as another option
as well, which I'll
talk about a little bit
before we move on to focusing
on one of the options.
And then finally, there's
the Legacy Backend Apps.
It's totally cool.
You don't need to take them and
move all of the applications
containers.
You're going to have
some things that you just
want to leave them
either running them
on your VM ware or your
virtualization environment.
Or you can use them
connecting with Apigee.
But with Anthos, you can
still manage VMs as well.
So as you take
those four buckets,
you can see that you've
actually categorized them
into these four
separate paths on this.
And that's why
customers would like it
when we talk with them with
like this prescriptive approach,
depending upon the
type of application,
and there's a prescriptive path.
For the first
case, if it's like,
just out of the new
Greenfield applications,
easy to containerize them,
connect them to a CI/CD.
And then take them to
run them on Anthos.
The second one is, if you're
able to take them, like I said,
cost applications
or you don't have
the source code, containerize
with Migrate for Anthos.
Again, run them on and then pull
them and run them on Anthos.
And then the third one is any
business critical applications
or Brownfield
applications we talked of,
we could use that GSI tools or
Migrate for Anthos or Migrate
for VMs as well.
And then finally,
Extreme Legacy.
But as you can
see, all these lead
to Anthos where you can
manage and maintain them.
And then you can refactor
and replatform [INAUDIBLE]
at your leisure.
That same three-step process
that I talked about before
with the savings.
So, from Google Cloud,
we were recommending
for those four buckets,
three options for you
to modernize these
job applications.
Option one, which would
be the focus of this talk,
we'll be going into
detail, is basically
how to lift and modernize
these application to containers
using Migrate for Anthos.
Like I said, it's
a great candidate
when you don't have
access to source code.
Option two is
Brownfield applications
with proprietary framework.
So for example, we've actually
partnered with some GSI tools
where we can help you take
your code, we look at the code,
strip out the
commercial component,
insert open source components,
and generate a GitHub repo,
which you can then connect
to your CIC pipeline
and get all the
benefits that you want.
And then finally, is the
refactor and replatform
options, part of Google Cloud.
We have tons of
frameworks and tons
of tools to help you
be able to refactor
and rewrite them as containers
with Spring Boot frameworks
as well.
But for today's
talk, we're going
to be just focusing on the
Migrate for Anthos solution.
So Migrate for Anthos
allows you to move your VMs
directly into containers
right out of the box, right?
Because it offers
customers a way
to migrate the workloads
whether you're running them
on VMs or bare metal.
This provides a low friction
path for any existing workloads
quickly moved to Anthos,
and provides the accelerated
migration as well,
and the modernization
falls to additional
cloud services.
So what are good candidates
to be able to migrate as well?
So any web application server
or business logic applications,
middle ware based,
right out of the box,
you can easily take
them and move them
to using Migrate for Anthos.
From a workflow perspective,
load duty cycles and bursty
workloads are great
candidates as well.
Some of them just use
them for training or labs,
but you can also run them
in production as well.
And then also, like, middleware
frameworks as we talked about.
Tomcat and Websphere are
great candidates for you
to be able to use with
Migrate for Anthos.
Basically, applications that
are built on enterprise links
are great candidates
that you can quickly jump
and [INAUDIBLE].
Now that you've taken
these applications--
and this is where I
talk about bridging
the traditional
and the modern one.
You take these applications,
you follow those four paths
and you run them on Anthos.
Now you can start using
the components that
come with Anthos, which is
Anthos Service Mesh, that
can provide a service management
in a single pane of glass
for managing your
metrics service identity,
and traffic management purposes.
And also, Anthos
Config Management
as well, which is
another piece that
comes with Anthos that
allows you automated policy
and configuration at scale.
So if you want to be able to
synchronize your configuration
across multiple
clusters, whether it's
on prem on the
cloud, this allows
you to make sure you do that.
Because it's also based off Git.
So it enables auditability and
review of CI policy as scope.
So let's put all of these
things together, right?
We talked about service mesh.
We talked about
configuration management
and running these
applications [INAUDIBLE]..
So out of the box,
you can take this
and that's what Anthos comes.
With Migrate for Anthos, we're
able to move these applications
and run them and manage
these independent of where
you are running it
below, whether it's
going to be on Google Cloud,
on-prem hypervisor, AWS,
whatever it is.
So, how does it work?
Very quickly, we
identify the workloads,
whether it's running
on VMs or on-prem.
And then Migrate for
Anthos, once we've
identified the
workloads, we take them
and we auto containerize them.
And now you're actually
generating the CI/CD artifacts
that you need.
So basically, Migrate
for Anthos basically
generates a Kubernetes YAML
file in a Docker image,
and a Docker file, which you
can then take and actually
move them into Anthos,
or connect them
to a CI/CD pipeline.
And now once you're running it
on Anthos, like I talked about,
you can use all the service mesh
and logging and capabilities
as well.
The key two important
things over here to remember
is it's not a lift and shift.
You're not completely
taking everything and simply
just moving it into
a Docker container.
You can see the things in red--
Kernel drivers,
Management Agents, Logs--
things that do not matter.
You're not actually taking
them and moving them
into the container
world as well.
And another key
important thing, which
is that it also handles
persistent workloads.
So as most of you
know, for example,
if you're running say your
application on VM ware
and talking to a [INAUDIBLE],,
once you've migrated it
to Anthos, it actually converts
them to persistent volumes.
So right out of the box, you're
already in the Kubernetes
ecosystem and how
to be able to use it
so it becomes easy for
you to run on Anthos
and get all the benefits like
RBAC, auto-scaling, everything
right out of the box.
So now that I've done the
really, really hard work
of clicking through slides,
I'm going to hand over
to Ameer to do the demo.
Ameer?
AMEER ABBAS: Thank you Harish.
So in this demo, we are going
to take a monolithic Java
application running as a
VM, use Migrate for Anthos
to convert that VM
into a container,
and then run that containerized
application onto the Anthos
platform.
So here I am in my
vCenter console,
and you can see that I
have a VM called Java-app.
Now this is a rel seven app.
Here's the IP address.
And if we go to
that IP address, you
can see that it's backed
by WebLogic server-- it's
a single admin server.
And we can also go
to the front end.
Now, this is a sample
app called Hipster Shop.
It's kind of simulating
an e-commerce experience.
And you can see from
the looks of it,
it's looking fairly antiquated.
And it's probably
been stuck this way
because it's quite
painstaking to change anything
in a monolithic application.
So let's take this
application as is,
convert it into a container
using Migrate for Anthos,
and then run that container
onto the Anthos platform.
And then, over
time, we also want
to see, how can the
Anthos platform benefit
this application as it gets re
factored into micro services?
So let's go into
the GCP console.
Here I am in my
Kubernetes clusters page.
And you can see that I have
three Kubernetes clusters.
I have a dev-US-west2
cluster representing my dev
environment.
And a prod-us-west2 cluster
representing my production
environment.
We're going to take that
containerized application
and run it onto the dev cluster.
We also have this third
cluster called m4a processing.
This is the Migrate for
Anthos processing cluster.
Now it's running the Migrate
for Anthos controller
that connects back to
our VMware environment
that I showed you, converts
that VM into a container,
and also generates all of
the Kubernetes artifacts
that are required to run that
container into Kubernetes.
All right, great.
So let's jump into Cloud Shell.
And first things
first, let's make
sure that we are connected
to all of our clusters.
So you can see that I'm
connected to dev, prod, and m4a
processing.
And I'm actually going to
run this demo a little bit
backwards.
I'm actually going to deploy
the generated artifacts first.
And then we're going
to go back in time.
And then I'll show
you how we got
to those generated artifacts.
And the reason is because it
takes three to four minutes
to get that application
up and running.
And I don't want to waste
anybody's time here.
So for me to deploy
it, I'm going
to create a brand new
namespace into the dev cluster.
So let's call it
hipster-legacy-crm-aa.
And then I'm going to deploy
the generated artifacts,
which are inside of a file
called deployment_spec_yaml
inside of the
hipster-legacy-crm-aa
namespace.
OK great.
So a bunch of
things got deployed.
We'll take a look
at those later.
So now, let's connect to our
Migrate for Anthos processing
cluster.
Now as part of
Migrate for Anthos,
we have a tool called
migctl that allows
us to do a bunch of things.
So first thing is I want to see
which sources am I connected
to?
Now, in addition to
VMware, we can also
connect to GCE instances
or AWSEC2 instances.
In this case, I'm just connected
to my single VMware instance.
Now migration plans are
stored as YAML files.
And if we look at the list
of files in this folder,
you can see that I
have a file called
hipster-crm-migration-demo-yaml.
And if we inspect that file,
this is the migration plan.
It looks a lot like a
Kubernetes YAML file.
And you can see a few things.
For example, I'm migrating
both the image and the data.
Remember, it's a
WebLogic server.
Here's my VM ID, Java-app.
If we scroll further down,
you can see exclude filters.
These are the folders I do
not want migrated as part
of my containerized apps.
So things like swap files or
boot folders or temp folder.
Right below that is
my image information.
The containerized image gets
stored into a GCR registry.
And here's the
name of that image.
Right below that is
information about data.
So here's the
persistent volume claim
that it's going to
store that data in,
and here is the folder inside
of the VM, the DB folder,
that it's going to
convert that data from.
Right below that is the bucket
where the generated artifacts
are going to get stored.
And here's the name
of the bucket where
we're going to store that.
And then right at the end,
we have the application name
that it's going to run
in Kubernetes apps, which
is hipster-legacy-crm.
OK great.
So let's go ahead and
generate this plan.
So, I'm going to, again, use
the migctl command, migration,
generate artifacts.
And I'm going to run that plan.
Now at this point,
it's connecting back
to my VMware environment,
containerizing
that application, and
then generating all
of the Kubernetes resources.
And then those resources are
stored into that GCS bucket.
So now that it's done, let's
look at that GCS bucket
and see what got generated.
So you can see that we
have the Docker file,
and then we also have that
deployment spec YAML on.
This was the file that I
deployed at the very beginning
of the demo.
So let's go in and inspect
that deployment spec.
And if you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
this is a plain old
vanilla Kubernetes YAML.
So, since this is a
state full application,
it's created a state full set.
It can also create
deployments if this was not
a state full app.
It's also created a service with
a service type load balancer.
So it's going to expose this
service with an external load
balancer on port 7,001.
And then right below that, it's
created a persistent volume
claim for the data.
And then lastly, it's also
created a persistent volume
with a GCE persistent disk.
That's where all the data
is going to get stored.
So those were the four
resources that it got
deployed onto the dev cluster.
So let's connect
to the dev cluster.
And let's change our namespace
to the hipster-legacy-crm-aa
namespace.
And let's look at the pods
inside of that namespace.
Great.
So you can see that we have
this hipster-legacy-crm state
full set with a
single pod running.
And remember, as
part of that, we also
created a service called
hipster-legacy-crm.
And it's exposed with
an external IP address.
And it's exposed on port 7,001.
So if we take that IP address.
And if we go to the front
end of that IP address,
which happens to
be at this URL, you
can see that it's
looking exactly the same.
The only difference is
now, this application
is running as a containerized
application on Kubernetes
in the Anthos platform versus
a virtual machine in VMware.
So very easily, we were able
to use Migrate for Anthos,
not do any kind of
recoding or rewriting,
and convert this
application into a container
and then generate the
artifacts that are needed
to run this onto Kubernetes.
Now over time, we have
refactored this application
into a set of
microservices and run
this on the production cluster.
So here, I am in
my workloads page.
And I am filtering this page
by the prod-us-west2 cluster.
And previously what was known
as the Hipster Shop has now
been face lifted and now it's
called the Online Boutique
Shop.
And you can see that it's
got a number of services
like ad, carts, check
out, currency, and so on.
And if we go to the services
page for that application,
you can see all of the services
for every single microservice,
as well as this front end that's
exposed on a public IP address.
So we can navigate
to that IP address
and hopefully, you
can see the kind
of the new and improved
experience of what
was previously known as
the Hipster Shop, now known
as the Online Boutique.
That's an e-commerce
experience I can perform.
You
Can do some shopping here.
I can buy some
vintage typewriters.
These are all
different services,
like cart service,
checkout service.
I can place the order
using the checkout service.
All of those microservices
are working together
to give us this
application experience.
Now part of Anthos is,
what we're trying to do
is bring Google SRE best
practices to our customers
that are using the
Anthos platform.
So here, if I go to the
Anthos service mesh page,
we are powering this
application by the service mesh.
And right off the
bat, we get a lot
of observer manageability and
security posture information.
So we get all of our
services that are running.
Note, we also get the legacy CRM
application that we converted.
We get the status--
health status-- of
those applications.
So some applications are
healthy, some are not.
We get the type of
applications, which
clusters they're running in.
But also metrics, like, requests
per second error and latency.
We also get some
topology information
for that application.
So if we go into
the Topology page,
you can actually see how
requests are traversing.
We can see the legacy one,
which has just has a simple load
generator, and
it's going straight
into the legacy CRM app.
But we also see
the microservices
based Online Boutique app,
which has the front end
and is talking to a lot of
different microservices.
And if we hover over any
of these micro services,
we get additional information,
like queries per second
and so on.
We also get health status
of each of these services
right on the Topology page.
The recommendation
service is healthy.
But checkout service is not.
So if we go to the
checkout service,
we can delve deeper into
an individual service.
So now I'm in the
checkout service.
And we can see what's
going on with this service.
So up top, we have a
timeline of the health
status of that service.
And right now, it's set
to 1 hour time span.
And you can see that
it's definitely been
unhealthy for the last hour.
Let's check it for one day.
I want to see when did it
start becoming unhealthy.
So you can see that
yesterday around 3:30 PM
is when it started
becoming unhealthy.
And what does that mean
that it was unhealthy?
Well we've created some
service level objectives
for this particular service.
So here's the SLO.
If I go into the
SLO details page,
I've created a single SLO.
It's a latency based SLO.
You can create one or
more SLOs per service.
Let's edit this
SLO and let's start
at the beginning on
what that even means.
So the first thing
I want to do is
I want to select my
service level indicator.
It could either be availability
based, latency based,
or even a custom metrics base.
In this case, we're doing
a latency based indicator.
And it's a request based SLO.
We go to the next screen.
I've set my latency
threshold to two seconds
for the 95th percentile latency.
So I'd like my 95th
percentile latency
to be two seconds or lower.
And you can see from
the historical data
that it's been creeping up
over time, all the way up to 8,
9, 10 seconds.
No wonder it's acting unhealthy.
Here I can set the compliance
period for a single day,
for example.
I'd like 75% of the time to
be within that service level
objective, which is that I would
like my 95th percentile to be
two seconds or less,
75% of the time.
Obviously we are
not meeting that.
And that's why it's unhealthy.
You can also sets
alerts that gets
fired as it becomes unhealthy.
We can also get into
further metrics.
Which particular
deployment is causing that?
So in this case, I can
break this down by location.
It could be a single
region or a single cluster
or a specific instance
of that cluster.
I can go very granular
into figuring out
exactly what's
causing that problem
and then go and
mitigate that problem.
In this case, we're just
running it into a single prod
cluster in one pod.
But let's say this
application was
running on multiple clusters
in multiple regions.
You can start to now drill
this down and troubleshoot it.
Speaking of security postures,
if I go to Connected Services,
for the checkout service, I
can see both requests coming
in and out of that service.
So I can see who is
talking to that service
and who does that
service talk to.
So I'm in the
inbound request page,
and I can see that I'm
only receiving requests
from the front end service.
And I can also see
the security posture,
which is this green lock,
representing that this traffic
is encrypted using MTLS.
Similarly, I can
go to the outbound
and you can see a ton of other
services that it talks to.
And every single one
of these services, I
can see the port as well
as the security posture
where it's all encrypted.
So hopefully, this
gave you an idea
of how we can take a
monolithic virtual machine,
use Migrate for Anthos to
convert it into a container
and run it onto Kubernetes.
And then over time, as we
refactor this application
into micro services, we
can use Anthos Service Mesh
to implement some
of the Google SRE
best practices
into your platform.
All right.
So let's recap real quick.
So the first thing
we identified the VM,
running in virtual machine,
that's on the left hand side.
We took a WebLogic server.
The first thing we want to
do is migrated to Anthos.
So uplift the platform.
We did that using
Migrate for Anthos.
We made the VM much more
lightweight by excluding
some of those files and
folders that Harish talked
about before.
And then we deployed that to a
staging cluster inside of GKE.
Now we can start using
benefits of ASM and such.
Now sometime later,
over time, we've
termed that service into a
number of micro services.
And at that point,
we can really start
to get the value of
Anthos Service Mesh.
We can look at the topology.
We can get the metrics.
We can start setting
SLOs per service.
And we can really start
to incorporate some
of those SRE best practices.
So hopefully, that
gave you an idea
of a lifecycle of
an application going
from a virtual
machine inside VMware
all the way to micro
services inside of Anthos.
Back to you Harish.
HARISH JAYAKUMAR: Thanks Ameer.
I know we covered a
lot of stuff today.
So as next steps, I'm going to
leave you with two links which
is going to help you.
First is bit_ly/java-anthos,
where you can learn more about
how you can use Anthos for your
Java modernization journey.
And then link two is
bit_ly/java-anthos-blog where
we're talking about the steps
that we covered today and how
you can go to methodically
to achieve a modernization
journey.
As well as you will find a
link for a free trial to get
started on your modernization
journey with Anthos.
Thank you all for joining today.